time Eric boss and dimple too is now
available on digital HD with an extended
version of the movie that they're
calling the super duper cut now may not
be an Ultimate Edition but it still
contains lots of interesting deleted
scenes and remove jokes the kind of racy
humor that might rub you off the wrong
way and how we don't need an excuse to
rewatch the Merc gleefully hurt a bunch
of people let's run down all the changes
in this new SuperDuper cut from the
theatrical version now there are a ton
of little alternate dialog jokes that
are spread throughout it so it's really
worth watching yourself I'm just gonna
cover the more subtle and more
interesting stuff to make sure that
you're covered spoiler warning and let's
get started okay it's starting from the
top of the movie the first major change
is the opening killing montage set to
Dolly Parton's 95 in this version the
first moment with the Yakuza it takes a
bit of a breather and Deadpool's joke to
the bartender is different and when
Deadpool pops out of the casket at the
funeral the super duper cut includes a
deleted Captain America shoutout let's
see Captain America yeah and unlike the
theatrical cut these raining Bills
dissolve into the strip club where
Deadpool makes another couple kills and
that ends in an e slide which neatly
transitions into Deadpool in the Yakuza
bathhouse the last major difference in
this opening sequence is an elaborate
360-degree long take that circles around
Deadpool four and a half times as he
fights them in all set to India music
director david leitch said he really
regretted having to trim down this
sequence to just a snippet for the
theatrical release it's great to see his
full glory here even if that means some
of the Yakuza are in their full glory
tale I mean after a deleted pep talk
with dopinder and some alternate ad-libs
by TJ Miller as weasel and sister
Margaret's bar we get to another big
deleted sequence if the filmmakers
promised us in interviews a suicide
montage of Wayde trying to escape from
his grief over an esse
leading up to him blowing himself up we
see him jump into a polar bear enclosure
at a zoo and chug drain cleaner before
jumping up a building this whole idea
was originally planned for the first
Deadpool movie as kind of an homage to
the Suicide montage of Groundhog Day
which remember actually featured film
jumping to his death even though he
couldn't die sadly this dark humor
didn't make either movie another key
change in this SuperDuper cut was the
Russell storyline that's Julian
Tennyson's character aka fire fist in
this version we see full scenes of him
being brought to the Essex House as a
runaway and me
headmaster and sitting in a lecture and
being physically abused in the
theatrical version these were both
hinted at via flashback in a later scene
it looks like the general goal here was
to be a little less overt about the
creepy motives of the Essex House like
also in the extended version Wade
compares the facility to gay conversion
therapy
that's worse than afraid a gay guy
really there were just a lot of
adjustments to this midsection of the
movie cables arrival and the present day
is more extended too with that redneck
conversation with Matt Damon and Alan
Tudyk making sneaky cameos under a lot
of makeup this new version is really
just Damon going into even deeper detail
about the benefits of moist pipes over a
toilet paper there's also a terminator
type scene of cable looting stolen
supplies that was cut perhaps the
longest deleted scene showed Wade at the
x-mansion trying out that whole domestic
nice guy lifestyle he labels the
leftovers in the fridge with one label
for wheels
obviously Wade's nickname for Professor
X what do they call you we use there's
also this added line with Colossus and
the soap dispenser I'm doing wrong with
the soup it's fine I just filled it give
it a few more pumps there this of course
is a setup for the punch line that we
hear in the later scene people think you
wake up a hero brush your teeth a hero
ejaculate into a soap dispenser a hero
and aside from some alternate lines from
weasel and from cable a lot of the
extended cut from here out remains
roughly the same but there was one
deleted scene showing Brussels and
juggernaut after visiting a big and tall
store and that sucks at any have
anything in your songs already want to
met you know and so jumping ahead in the
final sequence of the super duper cut
the charged music changed from rap to
fly like an eagle and Deadpool's dazed
moment with Colossus set to in your eyes
goes further with the offers of sexual
favors
[Music]
and then after Deadpool's self-sacrifice
his reunion with vanessa in heaven plays
out a little differently in a theatrical
cut the music was an acoustic version of
a hoss take on me here it's an acoustic
version of the out of ashes theme song
for the movie and there's also this
deleted joke it's pretty awesome here
you can have anything I want can
everyday the International Women's Day
it is heaven that is a callback to the
Calendar Girls sex montage in the first
movie
don't know as well as they just won at
this moment with way to Minnesota be a
bit more heartfelt and sincere sometimes
the life just gets in the way and that
brings us to the most controversial
deleted scene to this movie Deadpool
going back in time to murder Hitler as a
baby Ryan Reynolds talked about this
when the movie came out apparently test
screening audiences found it way too
racy that Deadpool would murder a baby
even if that baby would later bring
about the Holocaust this of course is
during the post-credit time-travel
montage and the super duper cut totally
includes a clip which plays right after
Deadpool kills Green Lantern Ryan
Reynolds boy howdy
this is a toughy yes oh yes here I
practicing a little salute huh oh that
makes two of us
but in case that comes off is too harsh
the extended cut does include one last
clip that rolls at the very end of the
credits with Deadpool actually unable to
go through with killing the baby I think
we both know I don't have what it takes
to do this so I'm just gonna change her
diaper real quick and then I'm gonna
come back with my friend cable
he loves killing kids ah see there's no
dead babies except for the babies this
baby would go on to kill or turn into
orphans I mean I'm just saying the moral
quandary isn't so cut and dry here which
of these deleted scenes would you have
most wanted in the theatrical version of
Deadpool to comment down below with your
thoughts or tweet me directly at EI vas
and Paul the new arc starts on Twitter
for updates on our videos like this
video sharing around subscribe to new
rock stars for all of our explanations
and the details that you missed from the
stuff that you love and yeah be sure to
check out our full movie breakdown of
Deadpool 2 for all the easter eggs in
this movie thanks for watching bye